have you ever done something really
stupid with money if you're over 12 you
should have raised your hand just then
all of us have some of us is more public
display of stupidity some of you are
able to hide it and isn't it amazing
when everything is going good when the
economy is going good the job is going
good the marriage is going good
everything's going good stupid doesn't
it you can cover stupid you can actually
make stupid look like you're doing
something good like you buy a car you
can't afford and everybody thinks you're
making it look at George George is doing
good you see that Corey bought that job
must be kicking it all George got was a
payment coming I was freaking earholes
that's all I was George isn't doing good
George just stupid it's what he did look
could you say the size of that boat they
bought oh my god you must be doing good
that new company he opened is deeply in
debt
don't we all do that you know once
you've done financial coaching as long
as I've done it when you pull up at a
traffic light you see a bunch of nice
cars all I see is payments because I
figure that's what most of them are most
people trying to you know buy things
they don't need with money they don't
have to impress people they don't really
like stupid on parade baby lifestyle
that is totally unrealistic and I can
tell you it's unrealistic because you
didn't pay for it meaning it's in debt
you have debt if you borrow the money to
do it you're you can't afford it you
can't afford it you can't afford it if
you didn't pay for the item 100% in cash
on the spot you can't afford it well I
can afford it I just wouldn't want to
you just didn't want to take it out of
your savings and you rather have your
savings then you have the item but oh
wait I want the item anyway and so I'm
going to take out a car payment instead
of paying cash for the car and the money
was sitting in savings stupid if you're
unwilling to take the money out of
savings to buy the car you shouldn't buy
the car if you don't have the money in
savings to buy the car
go in debt to buy the car anyway that's
really stupid and that's most people
I've done that most of you have done it
here's the thing though you can go along
when everything is going good and stupid
doesn't really show up but when you lose
that job when there's a health problem
or a car wreck when there's problems in
the family when the economy slows down
and customers quit coming into your shop
Warren Buffett says it this way he says
when the tide goes out you can tell who
was skinny-dipping stupid shows up when
you let the water level down doesn't it
when the economy slows down and life
happens and you're not completely ready
to rock and roll
you really were faking it you were as
they say in Texas big hat no cattle oh
the stupid can't be covered up then and
it just what was a little tiny crack in
your great theory suddenly goes bananas
and falls apart it happens on a national
level too it happens it on a statewide
level it happens on a citywide level
happens in a company and it happens with
individuals and families what feels
smart and might be smart when everything
is going good when everything's not
going good and you stress test stupid
when you stressed a stupid it will blow
up on you it cracks and just opens up
like a bad egg because that's what it is
your bad stupid theories can be covered
over with an income for a while well I
got I got airline miles on my really
seriously seriously you're going to
spend $100,000 on your credit card to
get a free airline trip that's stupid
well leasing your car is a good idea
because you can write it off really you
don't know anything about tax law I mean
seriously
my cars are paid for like
company owns them I can write them off I
can either write them off on a
straight-line depreciation to the extent
I use them for business or I can write
off the mileage to the extent I use it
for business which is the only way you
can write off your stupid fleece anyway
is if you use it for business it's not
sophisticated it's stupid it's the most
expensive way to operate a vehicle see
when you stress test stupid it explodes
when the tide goes out you can tell who
is skinny-dipping it's real you know and
I've done it man I put it you know
because here's what happens you put
these things together in your mind
it's called rationalization and you
rationalize well I mean this car you
know you know what we're spending to fix
this car with what we spend on all these
repairs we could have a nice car you
ever heard that one I've done that one
man you could talk yourself into a
frickin Bentley with that one I mean you
can spend three or 50,000 bucks on a car
using that bad gum math it doesn't work
gas mileage gas mileage is killing me I
have a $6,000
pickup truck and I'm gonna go buy a
$36,000 Prius and I'm gonna save the
money on gas you're gonna make 30,000
bucks up on gas mileage where'd you take
math what school was that you gonna
drive this stupid freakin Prius to the
moon and back there's no way you're ever
gonna make that money back on gas
mileage learn math skills kind of a
Napoleon Dynamite thing we need some
skills here man
unbelievable stupid when you stress
tests it is exposed I know I've done it
so many times D into um B so I'm not you
know everything I'm saying I did every
one of those things I did except the
Prius I wouldn't have a freakin Prius
but uh all my cars have like big gas
sucking engines in them I like I like
big cars you're compensating for
something Dave yeah possibly but I like
them and I'm old enough I really know
the compensating thing really doesn't
bother me anymore I'm old now so
I just want the nice car unbelievable
man so anyway I've done all of those I
had a friend that traded a really cool a
really cool vintage pickup truck that he
drove three miles to work and he
upgraded to a $37,000 pickup truck to
save on gas mileage because the gas
mileage is killing him from me and this
hook the old truck was probably worth
2,000 bucks but it was just like a
classic you know he's like a 72 Chevy 3
on the tree you know I mean a man your
Grandpa's truck that you wish you had
that that truck man
and he traded that stinking thing
because the gas mileage was killing it
the stupid things we do and try to
rationalize them be careful be careful
with your little theories because stupid
will be stress tested at some point in
your life and then you make an
entertaining caller on this show join us
this is the Dave Ramsey show
you